complexity
okay thanks everyone for staying so my
plan is to give an informal introduction
to probabilistic Notions of homographic
complexity
and the main focus of the presentation
is going to be on the definitions
or even like in the ideas behind the
definitions
well along the way I'm also going to
mention some results and directions
uh and because this talks being recorded
uh I'm gonna briefly review uh some
definitions so there's some overlap with
what you have already seen uh uh
shouldn't be too much
okay so uh chromograph complexity so
informally uh we can think of uh
chromograph complex of a string as the
length of its shortest encoding
and introduce K of X as a minimum length
of a program M the outputs X
so this is only an informal way of
thinking about homograph complexity
so more formally
so we fix a turing machine U
and we Define the Commodore of complex
of a string x with respect to uh as the
minimum length of a string M such that U
of M outputs X
and uh as Eric was explaining uh
there's a robustness in this definition
so if we pick uh we care for about
picking the Machine new uh then this
definition won't change much
so in the time-bounded setting uh
it's often convenient to take what is
called a Time optimal Universal machine
so let me just mention this so it's
possible to pick a machine you
such that for every machine and
for every input X and for every t
we have for this special Universal
machine U
H it's a common garage complex with
respect to you it's going to be almost
AMX
plus some constant C that depends on M
all right
and there is a small overhead in the
running time so it goes from T to
roughly t log t
uh and we also have a constant here
but it's possible there's a machine like
that and that's how you usually uh like
you formally Define that time bounded
Common Ground complex
um
so uh this definition for now only talks
about the Commodore of complex without
running time but once we fix this yo
it's going to be a time optimal machine
for us because it'll be mostly
interested in Time Around The Common
Ground complexity
okay so that's the uh uh about the
formal definition
uh however
for Simplicity so for this talk I'm
going to use notation and I'm going to
refer to these machines directly uh and
talk about these encodings
okay so when I wrote when I designed
these slides I wasn't hoping that Eric
would be in the audience
uh I'm just hoping that he won't leave
the room right now but so uh
yeah and everything I'm explaining today
uh is uh covered in a formal way at this
survey which I wrote together with
changing uh last year so fear and
applications of probabilistic model of
complexity and there uh we also
discussed in detail uh why you shouldn't
use this definition okay
okay thanks to Eric
but for this talk uh we're gonna follow
this convention just to simplify the
presentation okay
okay so uh time bound to Common graph
complexity uh here's the definition of
the unbounded case uh there are
different oceans as we have seen
and one important one is called kelly
Roti it's this 11 komograph complexity
and here we minimize not just the length
of the representation but also uh we add
a log of the running time to the measure
okay so the KT of a string X is the
minimum over encodings plus log t such
that uh this machine outputs X within
six steps
uh and there's a another notion of Time
by The Commodore of complexity uh which
is useful when say you want to talk only
about polynomial time machines and that
is the K superscripty complexity for the
fixed function t
now here we don't need to add the log t
uh but we focus on machines that will
run for at most T length of X steps okay
so there are these two Notions
um K uh subscript T and K superscripting
and um
High model chromograph complex is
something that has uh being studied for
decades in complexity Theory uh so for
instance there's a really nice paper of
sipser where from the 80s where he uses
time about the chromograph complexity to
give a proof that BPP is in the second
level of the polynomial hierarchy
I highly recommend you to have a look at
the paper
but over the last few years it seems
that you know these applications and
these connections between uh time on the
Commodore complexion or the areas they
have exploded and I just want to
highlight here three recent results uh
we're gonna see more about them probably
tomorrow so the first
is this uh characterization of only
functions obtained by Leon pass where
they showed that when my functions exist
if and only if Computing k superscript t
for uh polynomial T is mildly hard on
average
okay so we can completely characterize
the existence of cryptography using the
harness of meta computational problem
uh suichi uh has also found this uh
really nice result connecting worst case
and average case complexity
and the statement as there's nothing
about common ground complexity but the
only proof we are aware of use it in a
crucial way
so uh we also have application leverage
case complexity and finally there wasn't
mentioned yeah uh but it was also uh
recent and very interesting is a
characterization of uh the randomization
of BPP
using harness of another thermograph
complexity problem
so we can use uh timer graph complexity
uh in several areas uh and we have like
a already a quite exciting examples both
in crypto average case complexity and
the randomization
um yeah let's wait for the presentation
tomorrow
it's obviously very important to
understand these Notions
um but despite all this recent
applications uh there are still very
basic questions uh that we don't know
how to address about this time-bounding
Notions
so for instance if you believe
cryptography exists then it should be
very hard to compute levels complexity
uh say to show that this is not in p uh
it's one of these long-standing
questions we don't know how to solve
that yeah
uh Eric was also telling us about these
key results in common graph complexity
symmetry of information coding theorems
and
it will be extremely interesting to
understand whether they still holding
the time-bounded setting given the
number of applications we have for them
uh also open uh
and finally comograph complexity is also
deeply connected to explicit
constructions
where uh if you have an explicit
construction of an object then you have
a way of encoding it succinctly by the
code of this algorithm that generates
the object
and it makes sense to ask for natural uh
mathematical objects like prime numbers
do they exist and at the same time with
short complexity right that they have
short encodings
uh this is also uh connected to
long-standing mathematical questions so
we would love to understand uh these
questions and this time-bounding Notions
uh better uh but it's been very hard
hopefully in this program we're going to
be able to make progress
uh so what I want to talk about today is
how a more recent theory of
probabilistic homograph complexity can
give us some new insights about this uh
classical question
uh so here's an overview for the talk I
want to uh introduce this probabilistic
Notions and at the same time uh mention
one recent Advance related to to them
uh discuss how they relate to the
classical Notions the deterministic ones
and then discuss two applications of a
recently introduced notion called pkt uh
in the context of average case
complexity
but as I said the focus of the talk will
be really in the definitions and how
they were discovered and so I'm going to
be focusing on like why to Define things
in certain ways and you know getting the
context how I'm gonna use them so that
that's going to be the main focus
okay so uh let's start off with uh
probabilistic Notions
and by the way do stop me if you have
any questions
okay so here the idea is how do we Port
thermodynamograph complexity to the
realm of probabilistic algorithms
because this is the algorithms we use
everywhere like in cryptography and so
on so it's uh the motivation is there we
would like this Theory to be uh useful
also in the context of randomized
computations
but at the same time we know Randomness
produces strings of very high
chromograph complexity so we have to be
careful
uh so the definitions they are inspired
by the notion of pseudo-deterministic
algorithm
so because the this is a randomized
algorithm that produces the same input
with high probability
so we have a randomized procedure
if you look at its code it's a
deterministic object so you still have a
deterministic encoding but the way you
decompress your string from this
determinist encoding is a probabilistic
computation
and what we hope is that it generates
the same canonical output with high
probability
uh
so we really focusing here on the
decompression aspect of the theory
and uh so let's uh first look at 11's
complexity
uh so this is just the original
definition in the deterministic case
where uh we minimize the length plus log
t
and the way to introduce Randomness to
this definition is very natural
so now instead of minimizing over
deterministic machines we're gonna
minimize of randomized machines
so so you have a turing machine with
random tape that's the machine m and now
we say given a string X is rkt
complexity is going to be the minimal
over the length plus log t such that the
machine M outputs x uh in the most t
stats with probability at least two
terms
okay so you have this representation
it's likely to generate X it might fail
with small probability
and if the rkt complexity is bound there
you also know it won't run for too long
questions about this definition
is robust for amplification right
yeah that's a good question yes you can
it's a robust definition so if you want
to make this uh one minus Delta or if
even if you want to go from Delta to Mom
minus Delta you can do with some small
overhead
will they halt their t-steps for sure or
uh yeah so you could consider two
definitions yeah like you're talking
about like when it doesn't stop and it
produce x and t steps yeah the way I
Define here it could run like forever
but there's one change is the definition
by more than like a login adjective
Factor essentially if you're talking
about running times up to to the end you
could just start this exponent and with
login bits and now it stop the machine
more questions about the definition
okay so um
I want to uh
move right away to a result uh that
currently we can show for these
randomized Notions but we don't
understand yet in the classical context
okay
uh so here's the question is a meta
computational uh uh there's a meta
computational problem
and it's connected to this idea of is it
hard to detect patterns
okay so the problem is the phone I give
you an input X
and you need to decide whether it's a
structured string meaning it's rkd
complexity that moves into the into the
Epsilon or whether it's a random string
which has close to maximum complexity
okay and I don't care about what happens
in between so we're trying to
distinguish between structure and
Randomness for this notion of
chromograph complexity
and um we would like to show that this
is a hard problem
and in particular if you know
cryptography is possible we shouldn't be
able to solve this so that's one
motivation to study this question to
and a few years ago I noticed that that
if you look at these randomizing Notions
then indeed we can prove an
unconditional overbound
so this is in contrast to the
deterministic case but this remains open
so more precisely we can show that we
can distinguish between these two sets
of strings uh using a randomized machine
of Hazard polynomial time complexity
okay so it's a super polynomial lower
bound uh for this problem of estimating
complexity and it's unconditional
um
yeah so this makes the problem easier
because now I have a smaller set of
inputs
but in the theorem says it remains a
hard problem
any other questions
okay so uh shortly after proving this I
was very interested in you know trying
to make this positive polynomial time
exponential because you would expect
that there isn't really a better way of
doing it example maybe try out
representations of complexity up to
enter the Epsilon
uh yeah I couldn't do it using this
proof technique which is an indirect
diagonalization
but recently suichi has found a
different approach based on symmetry of
information
and he proved that indeed the problem is
hard for exponential time computations
okay so even if you run for to the gamma
end time uh
you can't compute exactly the rkt
complexity of the string
[Music]
so here let's say you want to compute
exactly so there's no promise
uh then you can show its model this
class uh the result admits a small
additive Gap
but it has an interesting Cadia which is
that you must assume that the machines
the acceptance provides are boundaries
even in the non-promise region
uh and I think it'll be very interesting
to you know try to unifying these two
low amounts because one of them uh is
for the approximation version of the
problem
and I don't need to assume bounded the
probabilities the other one goes all the
way to exponential hand yes but it has
this caviar uh so if you're interested
in you know trying to understand this
lower bound proofs think about maybe how
to try to connect these two approaches
or generalize the lower bound
uh and I also want to highlight like you
might ask why can we do it for
randomized algorithms randomized Notions
of chromograph complexity and we can
prove the singular balance for the
original problem like K Little T and
mktp and the reason is it's a proof uh
ultimately by diagonalization so you
want to use algorithms to diagonalize
and once we lift to the randomized word
we know how to do more things with
randomized computations
so in particular this proof here uses a
random self-reducibility which is a way
of moving from like uh to translate
between average case highness and worst
case highness and these are randomized
procedures so that's why we had to lift
to the randomized case to get the lower
bound
any other questions about this
sorry could you repeat that yes yeah so
these are like minimal complex problems
and in this case here the notion of
complexity is rkt so given a string you
want to in a given s and you want to
know if this rkt complexity of the
string X is at most s
must be what the caveat was I missed the
caveat uh yeah so in this statement here
there's no caveat it's like a
the there's no uh promise
but if you want to talk about
approximation version of the problem
right like you don't care about some
things then in this proof you need to
assume that randomized machine uh it's
from acceptance probability is boundary
from a half
although you don't care if it's correct
or not
something funny with the proof
okay so that's uh that means complexity
in its randomized version so now we can
also look at the polynomial time regime
of fixed time bounds
and here's the original definition of
Randomness and again it's very natural
you can consider randomized version uh
for for this notion uh so you talk about
randomized machines that run for T level
back steps
and output x with high probability
there's no log T because the T sleeps
it's just the analog motion
and yeah that also mentioned something
we can do with this notion that we don't
know how to do it with deterministic
case
so it's connected to the problem of uh
explicit construction of prime numbers
so I give you one to the end and I would
like to generate an NBA Prime and this
is a difficult question best algorithm
is running exponential time
and by using this uh connection
discovered by leaving that relates
Universal search
um and KT complexity this problem is
equivalent to showing the data primes
whose KT complexity is about hey so we
would like to show the for natural
objects they have small KD to T complex
in it
uh yeah this is still open
but once we move to the randomized case
together with rahu we show that actually
there are primes whose rkg complexes sub
colon
okay so we have short encodings for
infinite and many brands
for levels notion the running time can
be explanation so you get this log T
and what more recently we were able to
achieve together with changer is not
only to Upper bound the arcadility
complexity
but the arcade poly complexity where the
running time is fixed to a polynomial
so now we can show that there are
infinitely many primes such that not
only uh you have a succinct
representation but the running time The
decompression is also efficient
uh and again it would be really
interesting to get these results for the
deterministic case but we still don't
see how to do it
so yeah there's a great question so uh
the only thing we use is that we have
like a set of strings so let's say you
have some language
and
you have a dense set of yes instances
and the language is easy say it's in P
so for the case of primes uh we have an
easy problem that is dense and we have a
technique that says in such a case there
must be a yes instance whose complexity
is bounded
but it's a much more genuine result
although this might be one of the most
interesting applications
okay so uh but uh for most of the talk
I'm gonna talk about this more recent
notion called pkt complexity
which is also probabilistic notion
and um so we submitted this paper last
year yeah fortunately it was accepted
but one of the reviewers said
National resource obtained for yet
another variant of homograph complexity
you know I can't blame the reviewer
because there are so many of them right
but I'm gonna try to convince you to the
the business indeed a very interesting
motion you know that's another very
like you should be excited about this
new notion okay
all right so yeah stay with me uh okay
so it's a bit of a mouth the definition
but let's first read the sentence here
so what is happening with pkt complexity
uh it's called the say it's a
probabilistic tea time complexity
uh yeah so this joint work if Haley
Goldberg Valentin kabanets in general
they are here
so uh what we want to say is that uh now
it's a probabilistic notion
um but you can think of it as there is a
random string that is public and it's
available to all parties involved in the
computation
and now my string will have small pkt
complexity if given this random public
string I have a small description of it
a little bit more formal you can read
here so for most random strings so these
are like this public around the same
uh there is a small program
and it can depend on this Randomness so
it has access to the randomness and this
small program given the randomness
deterministically produces X from this
important
question yes is there some reason why
the length of w and the number of steps
is the same uh
I'm just assuming here that
or the length of M is K I'm assuming the
running time is T
and you also want the MW into output x
with infinity of 19. yeah so I'm just
using that you know if you run for text
apps it probably will only access T bits
of Randomness and I'm giving you the
state bits
that's the only reason why I maximize
the number of random bits to be here
right
so really it's the time and then you're
saying you're going to let you you might
have to think of it as a little time
step you're reading around a bit okay
all right uh yeah as you can think of it
in this way though you can access you
can have two-way access to it I'm going
to do it you can think of it as in a
different thing to take
uh they think like for this notion we
want uh uh chart for different business
complexity that's why I gave you like
two bits of Randomness if you're running
time tea
so we're trying to minimize is the event
for the programs
the only Randomness is W there's no yeah
okay so for most random strings there's
a small program that depends on the
randomness and it brings X so formally
pkt of X is we minimize uh over this
encodings and we take the uh the
encoding complexity such that given a
random string there's a machine with
small description such that given this
Randomness the prince X within TX steps
and T is this fixed function in the
definition
and just to contrast with the randomized
Notions we introduced before
so there we had a fixed program that was
randomized
that generated the string with high
probability this is more like so the
deterministic notion
but in pkt we switch the quantifier so
for most choice of the randomness this
is small encoding
yeah it's yeah I'm going to mention it
thanks
finishes the uh the overview of this
notion so let's now compare them and try
to get more intuition about this
definition just quickly so so in the
peak definition pkt m is determinism
uh yeah think of it as a deterministic
machine that gets access to the
randomness
yeah so you give W has been put to end
just because M subscription would be
shorter than
the length of w is that the reason why I
don't care about the length of w I care
about the length of M okay and so why is
it a w given as an input because and M
depends this is n depends on the
okay
and I don't wanna
like hardcore
is it like a yeah
like because you have like a
distribution of a deterministic machines
can be somehow with
yeah I'm not for sure but I'm going to
discuss the relation between this notion
okay so uh before that just uh to make
sure we all understand the definitions
so let's consider a setting where we
have two players Merlin NATO
and Berlin hold the string and uh Merlin
wants to communicate this string to the
other player
so the second player is computationally
bounded
uh but Merlin is not okay and we want to
minimize the communication complexity of
sending this uh string or a description
of the string
uh so now uh in the first case let's
suppose the deterministicated complexity
of the string is the most k
so in this case uh uh what Merlin can do
is just pick this deterministic program
of small length of length K and send it
over the channel to the player
okay so that's the protocol
and now ah to just take the program uh
running for T steps to recover X
the case X has a small deterministic
complexity we have a protocol like this
and it looks like NP right like uh
case of rkt complexity if the rkt
complex of the string is small this
looks like in May
so what happens we know there's a single
randomized procedure that generates x
with high probability so Merlin can just
submit this randomized program and now I
have to take the program uh use its
private Randomness and recovers x with
high probability
okay but potentially uh we might be
transmitting fewer bits because we might
have better randomizing Coatings than
deterministic
finally in the case of pkt uh
now we assume there's this shared
Randomness so it's this public run on a
string w
and what we know is that for most
choices of the random string w
ow there's going to be some program em
that given W outputs actually type
probability so now Merlin we'll select
the program based on the public
randomness
and submitted to Otto who then uses the
randomness to recover X
deterministically
most choices of this public running
string this would be a correct output
yes
how can M depend on can m
INE it can M depend on W and some
uncomputable way like I don't know if Wu
holds on FW is a turing machine that
holds yes
um yeah it's just otherwise I give you
an existential definition there is a
program although we wanted to run quite
mostly yeah but when um uh he chooses M
he can choose it in any way and
he looks a w and she's trying to
generate him yeah I don't care all the
time
in particular then it might be a choice
of the randomness which gives X
and then yeah the running is exactly
trying to save it
for more questions about the definition
uh okay so let me talk about the
relation between these Notions
so it's not hard to see that as you go
from deterministic to randomize and then
be probabilistic which is this am like
version uh we can reduce the complexity
of it and if it doesn't increase
you can also show that the compounded
homograph of the place is bound by the
TPT complexity that requires Anonymous
that is possible
and this is very similar in spirit to
these inclusions okay
these are the the simple uh directions
now it's currently open if we can revert
these inequalities and show the
randomized Notions for inside the
deterministic motion
but we can do it under a harvest
assumption
uh so I want I don't have much time so
let me just say that the same
assumptions we can use to the randomize
M A and again uh you can also collapse
these Notions based on these assumptions
so to summarize uh if we make strong
enough singular bound assumptions uh the
randomized Notions they are essentially
equivalent to the deterministic emotions
and in particular for everything X the
PK complexity The RK complexity and the
deterministic complexity are the same up
to uh unlock uh adjective
um yeah I think you should also be
limited
okay so uh that's great if you believe
in this highness injection any progress
you make with respect to the randomized
program complexity you can translate to
the deterministic case and this sheds
light into the original question they
haven't opened for like several decades
okay but maybe these assumptions are
false uh it means we can still develop a
fear of probabilistic model of
complexity uh fine applications in this
Theory but its Advantage is it's they'll
give unconditional results
that's one of the main reasons we lift
the randomized Notions because they'll
give us unconditional results
here like if you could if you could get
them deep then get uh yeah so for
instance uh yeah London team was asking
about rkdc uh you can also prove a set
of goal bars that if rkg and kdot T are
essentially equivalent then sort of like
e and bpe uh
perhaps maybe with some small effects
it's like analog to ma like is there I
guess if you define PK poly like a
multiple round situation because they're
like around collapse Lemo for PK yeah
that's a great question it's not
something we have considered
okay so let me move on because I don't
have much time
okay so these are the definitions now I
would like to highlight two applications
of this new motion PPT and they are both
in this context of average case versus
worst case complexity
so uh basically be careful of uh average
case complexity so we will have a
language and we care about solving this
language with respect to some
distribution family
I'm gonna say that this distribution of
problem language and distribution are in
average P if the following holds so
there's a polytime algorithm a
so this algorithm a is never incorrect
so on any input X in this for the
distribution either gives the correct
answer or it gives a fail failed symbol
so it's an errorless algorithm
that's the second condition and the
first one is that for most strings
sample from the distribution
uh uh probability that it will give you
the failed symbol AS small and as well
with respect to uh an input one to Decay
so it's like an algorithmic scheme it's
an errorless
algorithmic scheme for the pair l d and
that's average p
and we can also Define a randomized
version called average VPP uh the
definition is sort of like a natural
generalization so I'm just gonna skip it
for now
okay so uh the first application uh
considers the following question
so fix any problem l
and let's suppose we can't generate hard
instances for l okay so the assumption
is that uh in for our polytime sample
distributions
this language Al and this distribution
it's easy on average
okay so the problem is easy with respect
to all polytime simple with
distributions
can we say something about its worst
case complexity
I can't find hard instances is there
anything interesting I can say about its
worst case complexity so that's uh the
first question
and antonism for now about 15 years ago
they proved the following they actually
give a characterization
so for every language l
the language is easy in the sense Over
All sample distributions
if and only if
there's a fixed algorithm such that on
every input X so this worst case result
the running time of this algorithm is
two to the the deterministic complexity
KT of x minus the Commodore of
complexity plus log of the sides of x
okay so this quantity KTX minus
unbounded K of X is called computational
depth of the string
and they prove that this captures the
worst case running time
and this T here is some fixed polynomial
so the equivalence works for every
polynomial
okay so once I know I can't generate
hard instances for a problem
uh this is the same as saying there's a
fixed algorithm where I sort of
understand the worst case time Bound for
our inputs and it's connected to this
computation then okay so it feels like
very interesting connection right you
have average case and here you have
worst case
unfortunately so they result required a
very strong their randomization
assumption
which is that there are languages in e
that don't have sub-exponential size
circuits with Sigma P2 Oracle Gates so
it's a reasonably strong assumption
and that motivates trying to get rid of
this assumption
and uh what we did last year uh together
with uh Mario Simon and xinjiangle uh
was to show again once we lifted the
randomized homograph complexity to this
notion of pkt in particular we can
remove the Assumption so that allows us
to prove an unconditional result
so we have a similar statement uh the
problem is easy on average with respect
to all distributions
if and only if there's a single
algorithm from whose running time is now
two to the pkt minus K okay so to change
we had deterministic complexion and we
have randomized probabilistic homographs
uh and this is unconditional
so any questions about this statement
yes
[Music]
the statements happen correct maybe you
can also get some kind of
I'm not sure I think this is great
no more questions
some kind of universal search I am gonna
explain the approval again
okay so here's the uh sketch of the
proof so we went through the average
case highness uh with worst case
complexity
and uh the key ingredient to connect
these two statements uh is the existence
of a sort of universal time-bounded
distribution
uh which we call uh mu of T of X which
is roughly given a string X we assign to
the probability 2 to the minus p k t of
x
okay so this is an analogy with the
unbounded case
uh so that's our uh
how about the universal distribution
and what we prove is that
um
easiness with respect to this single
distribution is equivalent to easiness
with respect to our presentable
distributions if that's how you get
equivalence here
and then you relate the complexity of
the single distribution which already
talks about pkt somehow to the worst
case running times and you get PK team
the exponent that's the the proof
strategy
uh and I want to First tell you about
how to link these two things like
dissemble distributions and the
universal distribution and this is done
through a coding theorem
it's precisely about Eric told us about
in the morning but we're gonna need a
time-bounded version of the coding
period
okay and uh
so the main ingredient is going to be an
optimal coding theorem for pkt
uh in the unbounded case this coding
theorems they say
if you have an objective string and you
can sample it with probability Delta
then there's a representation of length
log one over Delta
and we want an efficient version of the
of the sphere
and that's where pkt shines because for
pkt complexity we can prove a similar
statement
uh while for the other measures this is
still open
okay so here's uh for the formal
statement so we have a sampler
depends in time T of n
and it generates some fixed string x
with probability Delta
then we show that since X can be sampled
with probability Delta we have uh it has
pkt complexity log one of Delta roughly
okay and the running time T here is
related to the running time of the
simpler
so we can have now efficient encoding so
if we have this public random stream
and a statement that is essentially the
same as in the unconditional version
okay so it's uh one of this key uh
theorems of comographic complexity that
we know to survive if you look at the
right Motion in the time-bounded setting
that's why I pick it is special for us
and yeah we as an open problem animation
we don't know how to show this optimal
result for rkt uh or for our case
superscript team so these are
interesting questions
okay so I want to explain to you how pkt
shows up in the proof why we need this
order of quantifiers and so let's try to
prove this theorem
so we have this sampler a and it
generates some x with probability Delta
we want to show that this x has some
sort of like succinct encoding
and the goal is to get this for pkt
remember the definition of pkt so for
most random strings
X will have a short description given
the renderness okay so that's just the
definition of pkt
uh and this is how we're going to prove
it so let's look at this sampler a uh it
accepts a random string of M bits and it
generates some string and we know X is
generated with probability to Delta so
uh that region is the set of seeds that
lead to X
and there's a Delta fraction of that
so if we could hit one of the seeds then
we could just run the sampler and
recover X so that's our goal
let's consider a fully random hash
function now that maps to embed strings
and uh
let's just compute the probability that
this random function is going to miss
this region for our inputs over our
inputs
okay because this is a completed random
function it has like it samples two to
Decay points then the probability that
it misses uh entirely to that region is
going to be a most one minus Delta to
the T to the k
and if we take K large enough this is
going to be a small constant
so that's just like a fully random hash
function uh make sure we pick enough
samples it's going to hit that good
region for us with high probability
and now I claim that
um
for most uh uh hash functions we're
going to have a small description of x
given the hash function right and this
is just by what I said so if you have
access to this random hash function
uh and you know it's a good one so we
know that there's some C that leads to X
you just store the seed and then you can
recover X
so that's precisely how the quantifiers
they get switched here so for most
choices of the hash function I have a
seed that allows me to recover X
and this is precisely pkt complexity
so there's only one minor issue with
this proof which is that
uh
this log 1 over Delta is large they
enter the Epsilon then the number of
inputs of your hash function is going to
be large too and to encode a completely
random hash function would take like an
exponential number of bits
while pkt complexity if you're running
time T you want to have access to just T
bits
but this can be handled there's a way to
sort of like de-randomize this
construction and that does the job
and the reason this is okay for us is
because we're not really paying for the
randomness
so when we actually randomize this we
just reducing the encodings of the
normal hash functions to be at the most
T but we're not paying for this team so
that's still fine
okay so and questions about this single
group
foreign
operation
okay so let's now get back to this
experience uh and I said the coding here
was used which established this
equivalence between like how simple
distributions and this special one
uh and the reason uh
uh the coding theorem gives that first
equivalence is uh related to the
following notation from average case
complexity
so we say the uh distribution D1
dominates
distribution D2
if for every X in the support
they have the same support
then D1 of X is at least D2 of x
divided by poly M say x is an N bit
string
and um
if you now use the coding theorem
you can easily show that the universal
distribution
foreign
distribution
so why is that so let's let's say this
is a fixed B sample for distribution D2
we want to show that the probability of
UT of x
is at least the two x over poly
so let's say this probability is Delta
now if you apply the coding theorem so
we know how to generate the string
probably to Delta so it's pkt complex is
going to be log 1 over Delta by the
coding theorem
and by the definition of this Universal
distribution you get back the original
probability we might have some overhead
but it's just a polynomial
okay so the coding theorem allows you to
show that this distribution dominates
anyp sample distribution and the fear of
average case complexity shows that when
you dominate a distribution then you can
relate the easiness of a problem with
respected to distribution
okay so that's the proof of the first
equivalent and for the second one uh but
now we focus on this single distribution
and when I talk about worst case running
time
um I I don't have time to tell you how
to do that let me just make an analogy
to the result from comograph complexity
so there's a result in Commodore of
complexity that says that is the
universal distribution for commonwe uh
for any problem uh if the problem is
easy on average with respect to this
distribution then it's also easing the
worst case
and what this proof is doing is uh
taking that idea and make it
time-bounded
because now we already have fixed a time
about the universal distribution okay so
that is there isn't much more going on
here
okay so that makes the link between uh
uh the first and the third bullet and
that establishes the theory
questions about this
okay so uh I have a second application
that I would like to mention
um
I'm gonna go a little bit faster because
I only have about 10 minutes
but do stop me if that's something you
uh you want to ask
uh okay so now we would like to relate
uh worst case and average case uh and to
um actually use this connection uh to to
get a reduction okay so one of the worst
case to average case reduction
and we know it's a major open problem to
achieve this to show that if NPS is on
average then it's is in the worst case
uh what was known until very recently is
that if any piece is on average then at
least you can place NP and two to the
end time
this actually follows quite easily from
the previous theorem because
there if when you assume something it's
easy on average
then you get this uh worst case
complexity
ekt minus K minus log
and you know that this is the most n for
any string
right so you get something this is on
average then the worst case complexities
is of order to the end that's a
different way of kind of thinking about
this statement
but you would like to do better than
that
and it was open until very recently uh
just to show if everything in polynomial
hierarchies is on average
then not NP but like verifiers with
unique Solutions you can do better than
two to the end this was a
biggest challenge uh and so itchy
um two years ago showed that how to make
progress how to use meta complexity to
establish uh to beat the inbound
slightly okay
getting to the end of our login
uh so unfortunately his proof uh is a
known Black Box proof uh that's how it
managed to avoid some of the previous
difficulties but it means it doesn't
generalize so easily to other models
because we can just use this easy on
average algorithm as a black box you
need to do something more so uh in
particular if you replace
deterministic algorithms with randomized
algorithms the original proof breaks
down
so we had to uh come up with a different
idea uh if we wanted to show a
randomized analog of this statement
um and of course uh
there are different reasons to care
about randomized complexity uh one of
them is
uh in this field of average case complex
if you have Randomness there is a result
saying you only need to focus on the
uniform distribution and not over LP
sample distribution so this is nice
and we also want to establish connection
between worst case and average case
highness with respect to randomized
procedures because these are the ones
we're using cryptography for instance we
want to make progress with respect to
the connections uh make sure they
survive in the randomized world
okay so uh what we did was to establish
this analog result for the randomized
case
and um let me just tell you a little bit
in like a few minutes about the role of
pkt in this group
so if you think about the previous
equivalence
we had the relation between average K is
easyness and worst case season s and we
had this quantitative exponent pkt minus
something
so if you want to get instead of 2 to
the end less than that
then you want to find ways of bounding
the pkt complex of strings okay so the
game changes to how can I open bound the
pkt complexity of strings
and
uh we have seen in the previous uh talks
that there's this very powerful approach
based on super Randomness right if I
want to up around the complex of a
string I can play to lose I can use prgs
I can break then and I can get better
encodings for the string so we use this
back construction procedures
uh so this is a key idea uh behind
switches proof
um
you're trying to Upper bound time
bounded Commodore of complex top strings
we're gonna use prism reconstruction
procedures uh they are randomized these
algorithms they use a usually randomize
unfortunately uh in the case in the
deterministic case
under the assumption that this NP is
easy uh uh Burma for now and Pavan they
show you could actually get the
randomization
so under the initial assumption
everything uh can be randomized so
that's great that's how you get around
this problem of reconstruction
procedures being randomized and so on
uh unfortunately uh
if we start with the Assumption the
weaker assumptions that NP is easy on
average with respect to probabilistic
algorithms this construction here this
proof no longer works so we can get
pages to randomize the argument
uh and that created the the main
difficulty
uh and in addition if you look at how
the randomness was used in this group
uh so the Reconstruction procedure was
randomized
and it required a small amount of advice
and the advice dependent on the
randomness okay so you have a choice of
the randomness and then you have advice
so uh that's the original proof
and so we were stuck here and how do you
get around this issue right
and so uh and this is how pkt complexity
was born okay because you look at it and
that's precisely the notion you need to
uh you know go ahead with this argument
so you want to have a notion of
complexity coming from this
reconstruction procedure
it's randomized and the advice depends
on the remnants
yeah so that's how it was introduced and
uh and then we developed the basic field
of probabilistic homograph complex in
this paper making sure all these steps
to be implemented
uh okay so uh just uh to summarize uh we
introduced this probably these Notions I
talk about the relations to the
deterministic case
and I gave you two applications
um
and let me mention some uh
directions one is to find more
applications of pkt and I'm sure we're
gonna see a few of them this year uh
uh the two that I highlighted they
showed like different aspects of the
definition
remember uh one is the prg
Reconstruction where the advice depends
on the randomness it makes it very
natural to use pkt
and the second application was in the
context of coding theorems because we
had the brand new hash function and we
had to fix the seed for it so again you
have the same order of 0.5
I'm hoping we will see more applications
a second direction is
we still don't have uh uh really good
bounds for Primes
ideally we would like to show that there
are prime numbers with complexity poly
login
but we are currently stuck into the
Epsilon so more generally we would like
to show any uh easy and dense problem
has a strings of very small complexity
so I think it's a it's a great Direction
and finally uh this is more like an
exploratory Direction uh everything I
talked about had some error rkt pkt you
could try to develop a zero error theory
of probabilistic model of complexity
maybe it will have some applications
uh and yeah do check the survey because
it describes all these results and many
more so thank you
[Applause]
question
yes
uh yeah that's a very good question
yes the question is what about deciding
PKG complexity uh is it easier somehow
and uh so is it uh use it to show her
I think it's a great question that's
something I try to explore
spirits
I also need the definition of PK uh in
the sense of learning which you can do
but again
even this definition itself has played
the role various results
so thanks again
foreign